so when I see you doing Bill Clinton for
example on Saturday Night Live that
means you've written the material I
don't write everyone else writes I don't
you just perform yes well that's a good
situation to be in have you actually met
him yeah I've done like three events
with him and in one evening I actually
spent about 20 minutes alone with him
why would he hang around I mean you're a
guy who makes fun I the faintest idea I
think you know he I I said something in
a paper once that he had 37 hand
gestures right which is
impossible you know you study tapes of
him yeah you do uh-huh and you picked up
37 different hand Gest I quit at 37 wow
and how did it happen that you ended up
in Bill Clinton's office I mean I mean
what he invited me he said hey I I watch
you on TV yes you're great and I'm in
the Oval Office in full Clinton drag
with the putty nose the fake nose the
whole thing you showed up in Clinton
makeup why though he wanted he wanted me
to play a clone in a sketch with him he
was doing for the Washington
correspondence oh I see so it was a job
yeah okay and then after that how did
you end up getting together with him
what were the circumstances under those
occasions that you were alone with him
well he wanted me to help him write the
sketch that we were doing you mean you
went there to write a bit with I didn't
think that was what was going to happen
but second you know lo and behold you
walk in and he's like uh do you think
yada yada yada would be funny if I said
that really do you think if I said yada
yada yada did you tell them you don't
write those sketches that you're the guy
who performs them I say him yeah I don't
write them I just read them he yeah
Lauren send over the guy who writes the
goddamn material for Christ's sake so
you so so you're sitting there with him
and you're writing a comedy sketch is he
a funny guy to write comedy yeah I
thought I mean his jokes worked really
well really he had jokes yes and not
only that he was a really good standup
really yeah this this cat's pretty good
when the with the spoken word and so you
you developed a a personal friendship or
no it was all work friends in in the in
the sense that he would occasionally
send me U like once he sent me a box of
M&M's do you think it's a case of uh you
know what know thy enemy like he said
hey this guy maybe I can tone him down
if I bring him close I think it's a case
of a man feeling enormously comfortable
in his own skin he reminded me of a
jungle cat that's just the most powerful
creature in on the Hill are you in love
with him was the presidency or is that
him is that the ultimate though did you
ever imagine in your career that you'd
be sitting there with the president of
United States writing writing a sketch
no it's all really surreal sural and
like when my baby was born 2 days later
she got a letter from him from the
president yes yeah dear me a welcome to
this world because in this Next Century
every person matters north and south
east and
west you used to kill me with your
Kennedy Impressions yeah but you do you
do but I just do the era do you do any
the kennedies do you do this dude coming
up with the way they speak like they
were sitting around one night smoking a
joint like you know it' be really funny
if we talk like this all the
time John give it a try yes not no it
I I never really did an impression you
know when I was learning Clinton I
learned it by doing um Kennedy's
inaugural address because I realized
that Clinton was doing Kennedy yeah
right yeah that's it's the hand motions
everything it's kind of scary the only
difference is is that he as Clinton
explained the time that I was with him
that um Kennedy's hand went down mind
goes up did he really say that to you
yeah I Ascend he descends